pray takes place in and outside the
Talos one space station and over the
next 20 minutes you'll see how zero-g
combat unfolds along with a variety of
different alien powers and weapon
upgrades and for more prey gameplay be
sure to subscribe to GameSpot opening
the cargo bay you could use I think you
can get back inside the station here
[Music]
[Music]
you find that open airlock I think
there's something following me
it's my keep hearing it that doesn't
make any sense he says just in my head
medulla
maybe I love you both mom I'm sorry I
know you were just trying to protect me
love you so much
vital signs
[Music]
mr. v io Equis I'm broadcasting to all
contacts in proximity please whoever is
out there listen to me oxygen is low and
I have no spacesuit an accident in cargo
bay forced me to seal myself inside this
container but I have no way to dock with
the station proper here
I see you Morgan we've locked down the
cargo bay we're safe for the moment
it will be a trick to get inside there's
not an airlock anymore that explosion
took care of that maybe you can do
something with the shipping containers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
wait wait what are you doing stop
stop down you stop
[Music]
move it
this is doctor diary Queen my last words
operator on oxygen he short is tomato I
only have its left I thought I detected
someone passing by but it may have been
my hopes running away with me first to
those of us my theories were correct
psionics are possible and the Talos
database will prove this out second we
are not alone in the universe
thank you at italo's in light of what
appears to be an alien the
administration psychic abilities on a
scale on a scale not even I had imagined
if only Maya doctor you it Morgan up
here
officer cool we can't open the main door
or our friends are gonna pour through
get up to
[Music]
[Music]
what
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
system alert to repair Xena please
contact data
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
ah
scanning target type of material and
[Music]
Kanak submitted structural upgrades
detect thank you
[Music]
get sick of waiting for them to come to
us
[Music]
Herr Doktor egg way was floating in a
cargo crate outside the ship
maybe stayed there he might have
survived longer than any of us
dr. yu were you up in crew quarters have
you seen any sound of my wife Nicole
last I heard from her she was on her way
there if you find her can you help get
her here the thought that she may have
become one of those creatures I'm sorry
dr. yu that was out of line
forgive me doctor egg Wei is blessed it
was fortunate you came along when he did
[Music]
God watching those things move we look
sick
what is it doing oh my god did it I
think I'm gonna be sick
it just made another one of those things
like it like you pulled it right out of
Enochs corpse corpse maybe I don't know
maybe it saved him it could still be
inna does it look like it Sam
promise me you'll kill me if I ever end
up like that
Sarah we'll get us out of this she got
us this far
so you came all this way only to get
back into Talos only way in is through
the door to cargo bay beam which is
filled with those creatures that your
brother insisted couldn't escape
confinement kind of like you I'm the
only one with the code it's yours you
can help us secure the firepower we
should have had when assigned here the
Eradicator turret fabrication plan okay
my men told me powers been restored to
the fabricator that was you wasn't it
I was going to underestimate you
we need is the turret fabricator plan
there's one in the safe in the Security
office but the hull breach puts it out
of my reach
if you have a suit
we could really
was the issue of fire
[Music]
mother suppose home
we're still my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you found the Eradicator schematic if
only we'd had those turrets earlier keep
an eye out for materials to build them
schematics half the battle once they're
built oh I can't wait to see what they
do to our new friends
[Applause]
in second your suit suffered some wear
and tear there's a rather complete move
it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
take that as a compliment
officer Maddox way
[Music]
the 80s are online and primed can't wait
until our friends get a taste of these
here's the code for cargo baby Arabella
very damn pp ends these small magazines
are for civilians say the word chief
[Music]